recall for an article 5 convention it
was just the policy of what limitations
our delegates would have at an article 5
convention and that was the meat of the
bill that was sent to us uh very minor
fiscal impact however part of The
Proposal uh would include a stipend of a
hundred dollars a day for the members of
the article 5 convention and those
members would be New Hampshire
legislators going to the convention we
didn't feel it was right to give those
members a hundred dollar stipend a day
in addition to their travel
reimbursements and and other
accommodations that were made for
essentially when we get paid 100 a year
giving certain members 100 a day in
service of their their work as
Representatives or state senators just
didn't sit right with the division so
the amendment 0752h just removed the 100
a day stipend everything else in the
bill is is the same essentially
for any future convention that may take
place
the delegates from New Hampshire are
limited in scope to what they could
based on the resolution that was adopted
for it so it's just a kind of broad
policy for for that future occurrence
but we just wanted to make sure that we
weren't giving
future legislators an opportunity for a
hundred dollar a day stipend for extra
work but while keeping the other
accommodations valuable
so
sums it up
any questions from
the members representative Weber yeah
sure turn your light on I beg your so
again you want to get my attention hit
your mic button so I'll see the red
light it's easier to see than whether
you're bloinking at me or waving to me
or any other things
okay
see no further discussion the clerk will
call the role that will first will
accept the amendment zero seven five two
H everyone should change your thing so
that change the typo from 572 to 752
all right
well can we do the amendment with show
of hands
all in favor
hands down any opposed okay the motion
is adopted the motion the uh
motion now is ought to pass as amended
by Amendment zero seven five two H
further discussion seeing none you're
ready for the question the clerk will
call the roll on ought to pass as
amended on HB 269 FN
representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards
yes thank you thank you welcome
representative Bean yes
representative hole yes
yes like Roseanne Sweeney yes
original Kimbrell's yes representative
Mueller yes
representative Waller yes
Rosanna norgren yes representative
leishman yes yes
representative Weber yes
Arizona Hewitt yes representative Heath
yes
representative evil yes
representative tolorski
yes
you missed me this time
God
it was a late night late night last
night and how would you like to vote yes
please you're welcome
and representative tolorski
again Yes again thank you very much
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
in representative Wilder yes Mr chairman
of vote is 25-0 in the affirmative
who's going to write the blurb
representative Sweeney
you have it written thank you
okay moving on to House Bill five of
430s no wonder we could do that just
then okay we're at 36 436.
the emotion is to retain representative
police
thank you Mr chairman uh I think all of
you may recall this was handled
yesterday and is in the budget
so no action needed further discussion
seeing none
the motion is to retain on House Bill
436 and it is included in the budget
well retained bills go in a separate
place oh
yeah I guess I guess 269 can go on
consent because there's or there is
money in it though isn't there
I don't care all right
put it on consent
okay so 269 is on consent yep
all right now we're up to uh 436 the
motion is to retain is there any further
discussion
seeing none clerk will call a roll on
the motion to retain on House Bill 436
which has been included in the budget
thank you Mr chairman
let's see if we can do this right this
time representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hole yes representative Sweeney yes
Reginald kimbrells yes
representative Mueller yes
representative walner yes
representative norgren yes
Arizona policeman yes
version of Buco yes
Rosanna Weber yes
there's no Hewitt yes
version of Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
yes represent haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0 in the
affirmative
thank you
moving on to house bill 571.
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman 571 relative to
cost of living adjustments for a certain
group two retirees that is in the budget
as due to our action yesterday
are we are we still going to pass it and
move it on through or retain the most so
that's in the budget okay so you're also
making a motion that we retain that's
correct is there a second second
a motion is to retain House Bill 436
which has been included in the budget is
there any further discussion
we just did 436
I'm not keeping track of my scratches
here all right house bill 571
is that is that one you also said had
been included
yeah all right Mr chairman
yeah so
um just to remind people this is in the
budget but with a very significant
Amendment as we explained yesterday
but the motion is to retains which is a
change from what is shown on the sheet
wait a minute what's going on here on my
sheet it says retained
it is retained right
all right so again we change what's on
the sheet and for you
further discussion on the motion to
retain on House Bill 571
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
on the motion to retain House Bill 571
which has been included in the budget
and who made those motions
leishman and Maguire
because we got on a couple of different
bills there
very good um representative Earth yes
Rosanna McGuire yes president Petrie
votes yes representative emmerich yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes it
was in a hole yes representative Sweeney
representative Campbell's yes
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative walner
yes
representative ogre yes president
releaseman yes
Buco yes
representative Weber yes
president Hewitt yes president Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative Ebel yes
represent Swarovski yes
there's a haken Phillips yes
represent or string them yes
and representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0 in the
affirmative
okay it's retained and included in the
budget
is it
all right what what are we passing out
now Janet
mission two amendments okay these are
the division two amendments a recognize
representative emmerich
thank you Mr chairman uh on 364
recognized representative Heath and I
believe she has a a different motion
um thank you Mr chair
um I would like to move HB 364
um actually ought to pass
um we did put this in the budget but in
fact there's a technical correction in
the bill itself so it does need to
um pass
what you doing
before the house yes okay so your motion
is not to pass so it can be in the
calendar so the changes are approved yes
all right
and who is the second
chief
representative Hewitt
your second yes further discussion on
House Bill 364.
this is representative Earth
this is the retain
what do you think because they changed
all right so you say you changed it
shouldn't be an amendment no there's no
there's no initially when I spoke with
chair Emrick I had thought we should
just retain that bill but then I went
back and I checked the language in the
in the bill itself and representative
Ladd had made a correction in the the
initial bill itself that we need we took
the action of funding in the for the
Career and Technical education students
but he also had some language a
correction to the statutes that needed
to go along with the bill so um I moved
to OTP at there's no Amendment this was
an increase in the in the amounts right
yes we increased it and is in the budget
okay
further discussion
so the reason it's ought to pass is
because of the changes so they can be
brought before the full session yes
and I can do the blurb if if you'd like
me to
everyone understand the situation
I want to explain for now
okay
further discussion from committee
members
seeing none
are you ready for the question the clerk
will call a role as ought to pass on
House Bill 364.
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
president Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes
representative poll yes representative
Sweeney yes Arizona Campbells yes
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative Waller
yes
representative norgren yes version of
leishman yes representative bucco yes
representative Weber yes
representative Hewitt yes
version of Heath yes representative
Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
Swarovski yes
yes haken Phillips yes
there's an Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman of all these 20 applied to
zero in the affirmative
okay the bill will go on a regular
calendar
because it does have some money in it
and representative Heath will write the
report
okay next item is HB 419
math learning communities program for
the Community College was included in
the budget we discussed it yesterday so
I moved to retain
you've got to made the motion it was
Petrie and Heath
got that not yet but okay
all right a motion to retain on House
Bill 419 the clerk will call a roll on
the motion to retain
representative erf yes original McGuire
yes president Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hole yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Kimbrell's yes River
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative Wallner yes
representative norgren yes
Arizona Leachman yes
representative bucco yes representative
Weber yes
president Heath yes
missed you didn't I
representative Hewitt
yes
Rosanna Murray yes
representative evil yes
representative yes
president haken Phillips yes
version Stringham yes
representative Weiler yeah
yeah Mr chair the vote is 25-0 in the
affirmative
HB 420 relative to the availability
funding for dual concurrent enrollments
this is the uh
running Start program we discussed it
yesterday and it is included in the
budget so I moved to retain
to retain
second by
representative P Heath okay
representative Heath
okay Emma Keys further discussion on the
motion to retain for House Bill 420 420.
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
on the motion to retain house bill 420.
thank you Miss Sharon
representative Earth yes Reginald
McGuire yes representative Petrie votes
yes representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campbells yes
representative popovichi Mahler yes
representative Wallner yes
yes representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative bucco yes
representative Weber yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative Ebel yes representative
tolorski yes
representative hicken Phillips
yes
there's a Stringham yes
representative Weiler
yes
Mr Mr chair the voters 25-0 any
affirmative
thank you
HP 430 relative to applications for the
education Freedom accounts program this
bill was required one year of public
school prior to attending or using the
education Freedom account program the
motion to is to itl made by
representative Weiler and I let
represent anybody speak to his motion
second here's who
me okay that's good okay this bill would
have changed the rules for
Education Freedom accounts and made it
more difficult especially in a case
where a family had
uh
decided on the first child that they
were going to be going to using the
education Freedom account and then it
might make difficult if a second child
had already made their decision they'd
already arranged transportation and now
they would have to had put a child in in
school for a year also would be if if
someone moved here and had already made
up their mind that they wanted to send
their child to a private school or a
charter school now they would have to
have that child attend a year of school
before they could
go to the one the parents desired it
seemed like
a
a needless reason to uh
to force the parents to make a decision
different than the one they had already
made so
I asked to itl this bill
further discussion
thank you representative Heath turn your
light on thank you um Mr chair
um this bill
came about because the efas originally
were introduced to us as a choice for
students in public schools wishing to
take those funds to a private or
sectarian or homeschooling
venue
this bill just reinforces that purpose
that was originally stated for this
purpose I think it is only
logical that we would include this we
find that during the first year of the
implementation of the efas
almost 80 percent of those individuals
securing efas never attended a public
school therefore I really think the
purpose that was stated originally was
not clearly intended just to Simply
arbitrarily be for
those already seeking
those already in private schools it
would be intended for those in public
schools meaning needing another choice
so I would encourage you to vote no on
the itl so another motion can be made
thank you very much Mr chairman
representative Edwards I'll be voting uh
yes to the itl I think the most
important thing we do in one of the
scarcest resources we have is a child's
time an educational window and the
parents understand their child's needs
and will provide for it the best way
possible I think as adults our role is
to support the family and the child and
uh and this bill does not do that so I I
itl
representative hacken Phillips
thank you Mr chair
um
as a point of reference I'd just like to
remind the committee that this bill did
pass the floor with a vote of 176 to 169
and it was referred to this committee to
consider
not the policy implications but the
financial impact of this bill
I will point out that it will produce a
considerable savings to our state to
control the fact that folks would have
to be in a public school for a year
before they could take those money out
of the public schools and that we are
not um
supposed to be retaking up the policy of
this bill but actually concentrating on
that fiscal impact therefore I will be
voting
um
for this against the emotion to it also
that another motion can be made and I
would encourage the rest of my
colleagues to remember that we are not
the policy committee thank you
representative Mueller
thank you Mr chairman
I completely agree we are not a policy
committee but the bill does have
financial implications and there's a
member of Finance it is my job to best
allocate State funds ifas do save money
and I think it is a place where it is
not a good Financial
you know approach to
have people spend more money so kids can
go to schools their parents don't really
want them to go to so I will be voting
to idea
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question clerical call a role on the
motion of itl
the house bill
430.
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
represent for Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes represent hole
yes representative Sweeney yes original
Campbells yes representative Mueller yes
Representative walner no
Representative norgren no
[Music]
no Representative leishman no
representative bucco no
no representative Weber no
representative Hewitt oh
there's enough Heath no
president Murray no representative evil
no
Representative tolorski no
hake and Phillips no
representative Stringham
no Rosanna Weiler yes
Mr vote the vote is 13 to 12 in favor
will it be a Minority Report all right
remember you want to have it written
soon
yes
all right moving on to HB 492
uh require the Department of Education
to provide the House and Senate standing
committees responsible for Education
with copies of the Law's rules and
relative education
moved on to pass representative Heath
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chair I move um are to
pass on House Bill 492 FN
and I ask for your support for this bill
this is um a bill that would require the
Department of Education to provide House
and Senate standing committees with the
education laws and the rule books thank
you very much and I ask for your support
is there a second
representative Petrie seconds
further discussion on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 492.
Mr chair
representative Hull
my only question is is this necessary as
a a bill or is there another way to do
this I wasn't in the discussion if you
can talk to that
representative Heath
um this was a bill that came to us from
the floor uh
out of House Ed
for some reason it appeared that um they
were producing
um
not the hard copies but electronic
copies
and
the the
committee felt that people needed to
have an actual education law book
and um
everybody agreed it passed on the floor
and our committee agreed seven to zero
and I think it's something that both
both Senate and House need so that
that's the purpose of this bill just to
make sure that we get those books thank
you
further discussion from committee
members seeing none
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 492 the clerk will call the roll
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes it
was in a Petrie volcise representative
Emrick yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hole no
um
Rosanna Sweeney yes
representative Campbell's yes
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative Wallner yes
representative organ yes
Arizona leishman yes
there's no Buco yes
president of Weber yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
version of Murray yes
version of evil yes representative
trelorski yes
Arizona haken Phillips
yes
representative Stringham yes
Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 24 to 1.
in affirmative
will there be a Minority Report no
thank you
HB 521 relatives of Department of
Education payment for placement for an
episode of
retreat
this was included in the budget so I
moved to retain
motion to retain
is there a second I'll second okay
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the roll on
the motion to retain house bill 521.
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes representative
McGuire yes
representative Petrie volts yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes president
Bean yes there's a hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative
Mueller yes
representative Wallner
yes
version norgren yes
there's an unleashment yes
representative
yes excuse me representative Weber yes
representative Hewitt yes version of
Heath yes president Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
tolorski yes
representative haken Phillips yes
president Stringham yes
there's no Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25 years already
affirmative
thank you
next bill is House Bill 529 relative to
additional Aid grants for schools based
on free and reduced price meals and
fiscal capacity disparity this was also
included in the budget so I moved to
retain
second by Heath
further discussion on the motion to
retain on House Bill 529 FN
seeing none clerical color roll on the
motion to retain
call up here
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie volkier supervisor
Emrick yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hole
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbell's yes
representative papavichi mower yes
represent walner yes
representative norgren
representative leishman yes
yes
representative Weber yes representative
Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
uh Murray yes representative evil yes
representative
yes representative haken Phillips yes
it was a Stringham yes
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25 is there any
affirmative
House Bill 540 relative adequate
education Grand amounts for pupils
receiving special education services
uh we got uh quite an education in the
committee from the chairman of Education
So based on his education of us we voted
to retain 7-0 so I move retain
ocean by emmerich second by Petrie to
retain House Bill 540. further
discussion from committee members
represent uh
seeing none
ready for the question
motion is retained on House Bill 540
clerk will call a roll
thank you Mr chairman representative yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards
yes president Bean yes
version of whole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative kimbrells yes
representative popovichi Muller yes
representative Wallner yes
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
version of bucco yes representative
Weber yes president Hewitt yes
original Heath yes
president Murray yes
version of evil yes there's no tolorski
yes there's a haken Phillips yes
I was gonna string them yes
president Weiler yes
Mr chairman of old is 25 to Journey
affirmative
HP 542 establishing academic research
and Improvement performance data analyst
in the Department of Education this
position was included in the budget you
approved Yesterday by a move to retain
Mary II
seconds okay
now Keith
all right motion to retain on House Bill
542 which has been included in the
budget further discussion from committee
members
are you ready for the question
clerk will call a roll
all right
thank you Mr chairman um representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie volcise
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin representative
Mooney yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hole yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative Mahler yes representative
walner yes
representative Morgan yes
Arizona leishman yes Reginald Buco yes
representative Weber yes representative
Hewitt yes representative Heath
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes
representative tolorski yes
representative hicken Phillips yes
representative uh Stringham yes and
representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0
in affirmative
HB 560 establishing a contact person
notification program to assist law
enforcement Personnel who have contact
with a person with mental or physical
disabilities and or
appropriation therefore this is actually
included in the budget we approved
yesterday I moved retained
motion by emmerich second by Heath to
retain House Bill 560 FN
any further discussion from committee
members
seeing none the clerk will call a role
on the motion to retain house bill 560.
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes
Reverend McGuire yes representative
Petrie votes yes representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
there's a hole yes representative
Sweeney yes
version of Kimbrell's yes I was in a
popovichi Mueller yes representative
Wallner
yes
there's a norgren yes
president abuko yes
representative Weber yes representative
Hewitt yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
yes representative chalorski yes
president haken Phillips yes
president Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman of Voters 25-0 affirmative
hb601 relative to State participation in
the Medicaid direct certification
program for free and reduced price
School meals this is included in the
budget it was approached yesterday I
moved to retain
shotgun
motion to retain House Bill 601
is there any further discussion from the
committee
seeing none clerical collar role on
motion to retain House Bill 601 thank
you Mr chairman
representative Earth
yes
representative McGuire yes Arizona
Petrie votes yes representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes Arizona
Moody
yes president Edwards yes representative
Bean yes represent a whole
yes representative Sweeney yes version
of uh Campbells yes those are in public
yes representative Waller
yes
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes yes
representative uh Weber yes
representative Hewitt yes representative
Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative of evil yes
representative yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
Aaron representative Waller yes
Mr chair the voice is 25-0 affirmative
HB 620 establishing a division of early
learning in the Department of Education
relative to a pre-kindergarten pilot
program this was included in the budget
approved yesterday I moved to retain
ocean to retain on House Bill 620.
for the discussion from the committee
seeing none you ready let me get a
second
Heath Heath good very good thank you
Mr chair
representative hole thank you
did I hear that this was included in hb2
correctly
did not include thank you Emrick is is
it included I'm sorry my error
we voted to retain it but we didn't
include it in the budget at this time my
apologies thank you
for the question seeing none the clerk
will call a roll on the motion to retain
house bill 620.
thank you
representative erf yes original McGuire
yes representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes original
Mooney yes representative Edwards yes
version of bean yes representative hole
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbell's yes
representative Mueller yes
representative Wallner yes
representative norgren yes
yes representative leishman yes
yes representative Buco yes
representative Weber
yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
evil yes
representative uh tolerski yes
you missed me again
how'd you like the bowl I'd like to vote
yes very good thank you
sorry about that
oh so
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham
yes
and representative Wilder yes
and through all that the score is 25-0
in any affirmative
HB 626 requiring the Department of
Education to administer the education
Freedom accounts uh vote was 5-4 Ito
motion made by representative Weiler if
you like to speak to your motion
what we don't understand we had to um
systems that's been working for a number
of years on uh education Freedom
accounts
the group that is doing that is going
out and visiting the businesses and
soliciting them to make the
contributions which are 85 percent tax
deductible to the program I don't think
uh a state employee would do the same
thing
plus they are working there's a there's
a short turnaround when they get the
applications and they'll work six seven
days a week in ten hours a day so
because of that um that short turnaround
and that concentration I felt that this
should not go to the Department of Ed
until there was a little more study on
how those things would be done because
they're kind of over and above what
state employees do so I felt that this
bill should not move forward without
that further planning on how we would
replace this effort and these people are
basically working for a percentage which
is going out and they're also hiring
people so that they get this work done
on the short time span and it's just
part-time people some of them volunteers
so to think we should replace that
overnight I don't think is going to be
successful without having the
committee on education do some further
research
please vote for itl thank you
representative Weber
sorry representative Heath thank you Mr
chair with all due respect um we're
talking about the education Freedom
accounts and we're talking about
millions of dollars
um as you probably all know I I used to
work at the Department of Education and
um the education Freedom accounts
currently are administered by a private
agency
um
no
in most cases where we have millions of
dollars that come through the state of
New Hampshire it goes to a department
the purpose of this bill is to assign
the education Freedom accounts and their
oversight to the New Hampshire
Department of Ed now the New Hampshire
Department of Ed may choose
to do a contract an RFP that indeed they
may choose the current vendor however
there has been no process picking the
current vendor
you know just as as a former person who
had to do the books at the department of
Ed and and look at the oversight I think
we're remiss in the our current budget
we have almost 60 million dollars that
are assigned to the education Freedom
accounts and their oversight is being
administered by a non
New Hampshire Agency for oversight I
just am asking with all due respect that
the New Hampshire Department of
Education have the oversight of the
education Freedom accounts and if they
choose to do an RFP to carry out that
responsibility that would be fine but at
least the Department of Education has
oversight currently the way it stands
right now
the money is assigned it
and the
um uh the the private agency is the
administer of those funds so it just
it's it's not
it's not the way we usually do things in
the state and I just am very very
concerned about it and I think this is
an easy fix
um and not necessarily
a huge change but there'd be a process
there'd be an RFP process we'd have we'd
go through the right steps if we choose
to do it the way that it's currently
being done that's another story but at
least we have the oversight of a state
agency looking at where it's going I
just think we're opening up ourselves
for huge audit exceptions I ask that you
vote no on the itl so an ought to pass
motion can be made thank you very much
the education committee was split on
this and then it uh
passed through the house when some
people were absent and we ended up with
it
um
the department of Ed I don't think took
a position on this and I don't think
they're prepared to take it over I hope
you will support itl
may I question
over here
representative Murray thank you oh yeah
thank you Mr chair
um it seems to me that this is a
reasonable and modest request that
overall has a benefit to the state
fiscally has a benefit to the state with
regards to oversight of the program and
a benefit with access to information it
doesn't seem to me that this is an
onerous ask that this is doing anything
other than being responsible to the
students of New Hampshire to the
taxpayers of New Hampshire I hope that
we could override the itl to pass this
as I said this is just a reasonable
modest request and it would be nice if
we could move in this direction thank
you
represent Hall
thank you Mr chairman in reviewing the
language in section 6 relative to unused
funds it does more than just move this
over to the department it puts a cap on
what funds could be rolled over year to
year right and we all know that
education gets more expensive in the
latter years I I think that there's
additional things going on with this
amendment and Bill I would support the
itl motion
representative Edward uh thank you uh Mr
chair I was simply just going to point
out that when we heard this on the floor
a member Rose and said that this could
be done at the department with just a
couple of personnel
um and so I went and made some inquiries
and I was told that they they brought on
10 to 12 people to handle the Surge and
we all know that the private sector is
much better to adapting it in changes to
demand than the the public sector is uh
I it was also pointed out that anytime
they have any administrative savings
they plow that money back into
scholarships and and and all of that
information is accessible because this
fund is auditable or has had Audits and
they put each student's account in an
online manner so that all the expenses
are transparent I'd also point out which
I think you did uh that the the
department is not requesting this this
is a political request not a government
request thank you
this time it's to speak
this time I really do have a question Mr
chairman and thank you very much I just
wanted to ask what the percentage is
that the administrative body takes out
of the funds that are dispersed to it
I think it's 10 percent
representative Heath
thank you um Mr chair I just was
actually going to say that the fact that
the um the current agency working with
the FAS take a 10 off the top of every
single EFA for administration of that
um again I think if it went to the
Department of Education for oversight
there may still be some kind of a fee
that's charged but again the Department
of Education would have the authority
over that agency right now there is none
thank you very much
anything further from the committee
members
yep representative Stringham thank you
very much
um I think it uh 10 no bid fee is not
responsible for something of this large
if if the 60 million uh that's projected
to be in the budget we're talking about
a six million dollar no bid contract and
um uh you know it looks like the
program's going to be here for a while I
think it's time to bring it into the
department of Ed they can do the work
themselves they can they can uh uh put
out an RFP and have a contract that's
the way it should be done and I plan to
vote against the itl motion
the bill does not cover all those things
you discussed
any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 626.
thank you Mr chairman
represent of Earth yes
original McGuire yes
representative
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes I was in a bean yes
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campbells yes
representative Mahler yes
Representative walner no
Representative norgren no no
I'm sorry
thank you
version of leishman no
original Buco no
representative Weber no
I was gonna view it no
version of Heath no
representative Murray no
version of evil no
Arizona tolorski no
representative haken Phillips
no
version of Stringham no
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12 any
affirmative
will it be a Minority Report
I already got it
already had it checked off
HP 638 relative to extraordinary needs
grants to schools this this was in the
budget
in Spades so I moved to retain
motion to retain on House Bill 638
further discussion from the committee
seeing none hold up wait a minute we can
use a second which is
peace okay
that's your chain
rechain yep
all right
you all shot very good follow the rule
thank you
representative erf yes representative
McGuire
yes
representative Peter votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes Rosanna Mooney yes Reverend
of Edwards yes representative Bean yes
yes
representative Sweeney yes they're doing
Campbell's yes or another
yes representative Wallner
yes
representative norger yes
president leishman yes
yes there's representative Weber yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
yes Arizona tolorski
yes
representative Hagen Phillips
or was in Stringham yes
representative Wilder yeah
Mr chair the vote is 25-0 any
affirmative
representative Hull for a question
yeah
did somebody vote no because I didn't I
did not hear that
I I have a hard time with uh
representative haken Phillips I said yes
yes
okay sorry representative Hewitt
sorry oh we're re no
were you a no vote on this last vote
no I was a yes vote thank you
so it was a part right hopefully
25-0 all right had a request for a short
recess as we get ready for division
three
um take about five minutes
by the way
foreign
so we're going to do these and then
we're going to roll straight into hb1
yes all right
wow
moving right along
no consent calendar and no Minority
Report
so
we're just going to do these four bills
and then we're going to go back over
here
you have a copy of your Amendment
thank you
again
all right finance committee will come
out of recess he'll recognize
representative Edwards division three
bills uh thank you Mr chairman
um I I have uh four bills on the agenda
and the speech is basically going to be
the same in all four
um but I'll do one and and then it'll
get pretty repetitive so so the first
bill up is uh HB 91 FN we voted uh
unanimously in division three to retain
this and we did put it as an hb2 item
the committee voted on the hb2 items
yesterday so this is this this is in our
budget proposal so I would I would move
to retain and I would need a second
second
that was Mooney
okay further discussion on retain for
house bill 91.
being no
questions or discussion clerk will call
a role to retain hb91
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes representative
McGuire
yes representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative uh Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes represent a bean yes it was
in a poll yes
I'm sorry I yes thank you
representative Sweeney yes original
Campbells yes Reginald popovichi Mueller
yes
representative Wallner yes
yes representative organ yes
representative leishman
representative buco
yes
representative Weber yes Hewitt
he's not there okay
representative Heath yes
Murray yes represent of evil yes
president zolorski
yes
president haken Phillips
yeah
version of Stringham
yes
version Weiler yes
Mr chair in the vote is 24-0
affirmative
uh thank you Mr chair I I probably
should at least read the title in 91
relative to privacy obligations of the
Department of Health and Human Services
now now on to House Bill 282 this is
relative to including certain children
and pregnant women in Medicaid and the
children's health insurance program
commonly known as chip we voted in
Committee in division three to retain
this on a seven to one vote yesterday uh
Finance accepted it as an hb2 item and
that justifies retaining this bill in my
opinion our move to retain and need a
second second
motion is not is to retain House Bill
282 further discussion from the
committee
seeing none
clerk will call the roll on the motion
to retain HB 282 thank you Miss Sherman
representative erf yes president McGuire
yes representative Petrie votes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hole yes representative Sweeney yes
representative kimbrells yes
representative Mueller yes
representative walner yes
yes representative leishman yes
representative bucco yes representative
Weber
yes representative
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
representative yes
representative Higgin Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
yes Mr chair the vote is 24-0 in the
affirmative
to retain
thanks Bill
uh thank you Mr chair
um I I want to speak to house bill 565.
this is relative to expanding Medicaid
to include certain postpartum Health
Care Services uh Division III uh voted
to retain this seven to one this was in
the hb2 packet that was voted on and
accepted yesterday so retaining
retaining is the proper motion I need a
second
further discussion on the motion to
retain house bill 565.
representative papovich okay
see no discussion the clerk will call a
roll on the motion to retain House Bill
565. thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes representative
McGuire yes representative Petrie votes
yes representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hole yes Rosanna Sweeney
yes representative yes
representative Mueller yes Rosanna
walner yes Rosa norgren yes Rosanna
leishman yes
Arizona bucco yes
representative Weber
yes
representative Heath yes
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative tolorski
yes
representative hicken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes Mr chair the
vote is 24-0 in affirmative
uh thank you Mr chair so far I think I'm
going to do all the blurbs on the
previous bills so uh
I know no blurbs necessary
well week week lame humor
uh House Bill 614
uh this is the same story
um on in this one we're making an
appropriation to the Department of
Health and Human Services to fund the
Merrimack New Hampshire kidney cancer
incidence phase three feasibility study
um I uh the proper motion here is to
retain I need a second
second
if I may speak just please so so what we
did was we put this in the hospital too
and we voted that out yesterday so
there's no need for this bill to go back
to the floor
further discussion from members of the
committee on house bill 614
seeing none you ready for the question
the clerk will call the roll on retain
for house bill 614.
my name is Sharon
representative Earth yes representative
McGuire yes representative Petrie volt
yes representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative whole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campbell's
yes representative Mueller yes
representative Wallner
yes
representative norgren yes
hman yes
representative bucco yes
representative Weber yes
representative you no no no okay
represent Heath yes
representative Murray yes there's an
evil yes
representative Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Wilder yes
Mr chair the vote is 24-0 in the
affirmative
thank you
it concludes our bills we're going to
move again to Vision three and go to
their hb1 changes while we're getting
ready for that I'm going to read you a
notice you may be interested in
please join the community college system
of New Hampshire for a meet and greet in
the State House cafeteria Tuesday March
28th from 11 to 1. legislators are
invited to join college and system
leaders and discuss education and
Workforce Development issues of
importance to your region and the state
that's almost a long run-on sentence
Refreshments provided by culinary
students from Lakes Region and White
Mountain community colleges will be
served the committee that leaves us the
most business cards will win
a gorgeously decorated and delicious
cake made by pastry arts students
so
I hope you all have business cards to
take over there and drop
it so
what's that
I said it was it sounded like a stack
deck to me because this is of course the
biggest committee
and it's here today
to go to participate
okay
Vision three
chairman and vice chairman and LBA will
present
your hb1 changes
uh thank you Mr chair
um for the committee we're going to go
through the HP one items that we didn't
get to yesterday
um and uh yesterday I I started with uh
voicing gratitude to the LBA uh and on
and to the department but um just based
on the amount of work that Mr Ripple had
thrown at him in the last 12 hours
yesterday's gratitude needs to be
renewed because he stepped up and he's
provided some some more for us so uh
I'll I'll I'll I'll bring you up to
speed on those when we get to them
the first thing is uh on row two and
three these two rows are now in house
bill 2. we discussed that at length
yesterday and um and so I I don't
believe there should be any questions if
you want to consult back this is a house
bill Amendment
2023-0972 hotel in your packet from
yesterday
um I'll I'll just keep going if unless
you see questions Mr chair
um the the next item
um or is uh on line six relative to new
heights New Heights is the integrated
eligibility system that's how it was
listed
do we have a question from
representative Stringham no
okay thank you okay so new heights is
the integrated eligibility system we
discussed it as part of the package
yesterday there was an observation made
as we were talking about it that we have
to find ways to help the department be
more productive and so this is uh the
I.T approach to evolving their uh their
eligibility system and Crossing more and
more areas so this this will fund an
audit of that eligibility system because
as they expand the scope of what it does
they have to make sure that they're they
meet the terms of compliance so this was
discussed in
2023-1172 hotel and it's now in the hb2
packet
next item is um
lines 9 and 10.
this is a pretty significant amount of
money
the first the top line on the 20.5
million is General the bottom line or
the next line down is
65.688 over the biennium that that
second amount is the budget Federal the
federal matching funds that come with
the general funds so
um this is to me an absolutely shocking
amount of money uh and I uh and and but
we're we're moving this out of House
Bill 2 and into house bill one because
it's it's really operations and
maintenance and not a major systems
upgrade and so as an operations and
maintenance item despite the enormity of
it it really belongs uh in hb1 so this
is a no-cost move
um but it does make it more transparent
we did that in Amendment 1059 hotel and
a prove that then
next line item question go ahead
question representative McGuire thank
you Mr chairman thank you
um is Medicaid now generally a 3X plus
matching this seems awfully high no
I I this this is a correct matching
number and I don't see uh Mr White do
you want to talk to the matching uh
because that is a high match
he's back there but Medicaid is
typically 50 50 but in the case of mmis
it's a much higher Federal match
uh thank you for the question
um
next lines 13 and 14 uh the the the
Undisputed subject matter expert on this
is a representative erf this is the
second year that we've done something
different uh we discussed it at length
yesterday as part of 2023-0870
um and uh the these these monies
represent the general funds money that
will go to the counties uh in the case
of Hillsboro or not Hillsborough my
county is Rockingham County the case of
Rockingham County the CFO told me that
this change in what we did for them the
last term that we're carrying into this
term at the exact same rate or the same
dollar amount uh shaved seven percentage
points off of the county share of the
property tax so so if you vote for this
keep in mind that you should tell your
taxpayers that we we are actually doing
something to reduce their candidate
County property taxes
I'll move on
um
food protection on lines uh 17 and 18.
this was a prioritized need request from
the Department uh what this does is
allows them to pay overtime during the
busy recreational summer months they're
going out to the they spent a lot more
time at the recreation recreational hot
spots food trucks that sort of thing
trying to make sure that we don't have
any foodborne illnesses spread because I
think we all know what an outbreak would
do to our reputation our tourism so so
what the if if we didn't give them this
money what they would end up having to
do is is take their existing employees
and work around and give them
uncompensated time off later in the year
so so this is this just seemed to me to
fit fit the surge requirement I don't
believe we talked about about this
yesterday though so if there are any
questions I'd take any
okay I'm not I'm not saying anything Mr
chair
um okay so so number 19. a
representative kofault I think it was
really good that he was here yesterday
because he uh he he shook me a little
bit and he said hey you know that the
house bill that did the wick
supplemental nutrition program for three
hundred thousand dollars a year was was
killed in on the floor uh and I had not
recalled that uh and so so I I think
it's inappropriate for us to go ahead
and put that money in when when the
house policy didn't meet it but uh with
that 300 and 300 we have uh an amendment
that I'd like to offer Mr chair at this
point this seems like a good a good
point to bring it up
um as Mr Ripple hands out the amendment
um
let me describe it
representative Mooney I've been
struggling all day on the proper name of
that organization the home visits
there's like five words in there
m-i-e-c-h-v maternal infant and early
development home visiting so so this was
a program that had asked for money that
hadn't uh completely made it into the
way into the governor's budget there was
um it came over to us with a 109 well
we'll call it a hundred and ten thousand
dollars on the governor's budget they
requested a very large increase from 110
to 525 and what this amendment proposes
this amendment proposes that uh instead
of agreeing to their 525 increase we're
we're taking the 300 that just got freed
up by the WIC supplemental nutrition
program
so um so I only had a brief moment to
discuss this with representative Wallner
before this uh and you know if she has
any comments
um and now that she's seen it or
represented tolersky
any questions or discussion from
committee members
representative thank you Mr chairman
um
this is the first time I'm seeing this
um everyone on division three
we were within the last two hours of our
work day
when
I requested we discuss this
line item
19.
and those of you who were there know
that I was quite
enthusiastic
and impassioned about this program
and we did discuss that it had come to
the floor and had not passed and was
that a priority item for the Department
we had
a detailed discussion on the pros and
cons and in the end
the division voted in a bipartisan way
to put it in hb1 with a vote of six to
three
and I am
disappointed that this is the first time
I'm hearing about this
and I wish that the sponsor of this
amendment could have discussed it with
me prior
at the same time I understand the need
for the home visiting money
as we also attempted to fund that on
that evening
so while I understand the importance
of both
I guess I'm going to sit and see if
there's more discussion but I just
wanted to make sure that I set the
record straight that we did discuss the
WIC program quite extensively on our
last night of work thank you for letting
me speak
so I I would say to that that because
you had a particular passion on it I I
would yeah you you're more likely to
remember it accurately I I'm just saying
that my recollection is that that I
don't recall us talking about the bill
being it old on the floor
that's something that probably just got
by me or because that that is a
significant fact to me but um but I
don't I don't disagree with you I just
saying we remember it different
usually the things that pass the house
we try to put in the budget but if
they're inexpedient we do not
representative
representative Wallner thank you
well this is a difficult choice because
both of these programs are really needed
by
low-income families in New Hampshire so
if this is a very very difficult choice
and I think that we did vote in our
division to include the WIC program the
funding for it
and the home visiting program also is
extremely important in that
um it does have it also has a very a
very substantial Federal match and would
really benefit the families
but at this point I think I'm going to
vote I think I'm going to vote no on it
because I just heard about it
well just before we right when we broke
and
um
I just don't like the idea of these
coming in as one trade-off for the other
and so if I am going to vote no
so represent Weiler we are bringing this
rather late and
um I don't need to bring this amendment
forward
um but I I based on
understanding now that this item got it
yelled uh I I would be ready to make a
motion to delete line 19 from the
recommendations and save the 600 000
because we've got a lot of different
ways to spend six hundred thousand
dollars not the least of which is to
improve our Medicaid reimbursement rates
so so the first motion I would make if
if I could you may uh is I would like to
move to strike line 19.
what are you waving at no question I'll
second emotion okay discussion
representative nordgren well uh
I'm wondering if maybe we all have
issues in Remembering exactly what
happened but often what happens on the
floor is that a bill will be voted itl
when we know we're dealing with it in
finance so I'm wondering if maybe we're
all sort of forgetting
parts of what happened on the floor and
that we should be including it as we see
it here as as we like to say to one
another whenever it's the right time for
us to say it uh there's the policy
Choice and then there's a financial
choice in the and the body is fairly
well trained on when they're doing what
so the previous failure for this to pass
on the floor was a policy vote then it
comes to us for the financial vote and
in this case I'm not comfortable going
forward realizing that this policy
failed on the floor as a matter of
policy
so I
further discussion on the motion to
delete line 19 on hb1 here before us
representative Holm
thank you Mr chairman
um I believe this was house bill 574. it
came out as an auto pass motion and was
in fact defeated and then laid on the
table and then voted in which also
failed and then in expedient to
legislate so
um the house has made a decision on this
I'm in support of The house's decision
further discussion
what shall we label uh or just the
amendment will just be deletion of line
19. yeah strike row 19. further
discussion seeing none clerk will call a
role on the motion to delete line 19
from this pager looking at division
three category five
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes president McGuire
yes representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes represent
a bean yes represent of whole yes
representative Sweeney yes professional
kimbrells yes representative papavichi
Mueller yes
representative Wallner no
Representative norgren no
Rosanna leishman no
version of buco no
representative Weber no version of you
it nope
version of Heath no
person Murray no representative evil no
president tlerski no representative Bill
haken Phillips no
Russian Stringham nope
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12 in
favor of the motion
the line is deleted
um Mr chair if it's appropriate now I
would like to make a motion uh to to
pass an hb1 amendment the description of
this is to fund the home visiting
formula grant with three hundred
thousand dollars per year of General
funds that were previously budgeted for
the Wic Farmers Market program
as was mentioned before uh this this
this may have a nice Federal match to it
but I don't see it on here
the Department's request did not include
a federal matching number so this is
yeah their prioritized needs request was
General funds only okay but if we if we
if we go ahead and and do the general
funds they can later go back and ask for
additional federal funds or or have we
missed that window
possibly I'm not sure if it applies to
this program or not okay all right
um
there there are some other federal funds
Associated here so presumably there's a
match
um so I I would I would move this to
pass and I would need a second second
further discussion from committee
members what's the what's the motion
fund adopt amendment to hb1
I guess it doesn't have a number Mr
Ripple
representative thank you Mr chairman
um can you refresh my memory on the
amount that the department had requested
that we hadn't funded yet what we passed
which I believe was a percentage and
where this 300 000 will leave us
for for this the the department being
the governor's budget uh was just under
a hundred and ten thousand the
department uh then had a prioritized
need of an additional 525
000. so what we would be doing is we
would be
giving most of the prioritize need 300
000 of the 525 extra
to the department so that they could
support
the home visiting formula grant
follow-up
line item for the prioritized request in
the
Millions
no there are millions once you had the
federal money
but here you you can look at this and
and this is what you've probably seen
thank you for the clarification
representative Mooney I found it
further discussion on the motion to
adopt this hb1 amendment
seeing none the clerk will call a role
on the motion to amend hb1
thank you
representative erf yes
version of McGuire yes representative
yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards
representative Bean yes there's a hole
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative papovichi Mueller yes
representative walner yes
president norgren yes
yes
original bucco yes
representative Weber yes version of
Hewitt yes
version of Heath yes
representative Murray yes version of
evil yes
representative yes
and Phillips
yes
representative Stringham yes
original Weiler
yes
Mr chairman of old is 25 to zero in any
affirmative tonight representative hack
and Phillips were you in no vote
I'm so sorry I don't know why everyone
has a hard time I'm saying yes I have
said yes
all right
I I heard yes so hopefully that's what
it was
so uh thank you Mr chair should I keep
moving through the spreadsheet please do
okay uh row 20 on page two
um this is uh this could really be
categorized as a technical adjustment uh
this is intended to uh take hb2 and
reduce the federal funds so that it
aligns with the actual amount and a
Federal grant award
um
there's not much to say there
uh item
uh this is for the Glencliff home we did
not make any change to uh their their
request uh item 26 uh the Prevention
Services and this is a program that was
requested by representative tolersky uh
this is I think the first time that the
general funds have been set up to be
appropriated to a collaboration of five
different organizations working on
substance abuse issues the initial
request was 625
000 total or per year and and um and we
reduced it to 200 000 and I I personally
was confused over how the match would
work so I I thought until we could
figure it out and given this is the
first year two hundred thousand dollars
would be uh the right number
um on 27
I think there are two but this is
certainly the first one we've come
across this is
um related to
um
some ear marking of commission funds for
the alcohol and drug abuse commission
and the the net of this is a 2.1 over
the biennium what we've what we're
trying to do is with HB
um 223 1204 is to safeguard the
legislative commitment for five percent
of the alcohol sales to go to the
commission
that number has has historically been
more in the four percent range it's been
a little lower if you go back in history
even further so this is the first time
that we're going to you know explicitly
make our commitment that we said five
percent we mean five percent uh and and
here it is
and you can see the math that on revenue
of 11.1 million how much that would be
so this is a A plus up to them of 2.1
million over the biennium
not seeing any comments there the next
one is line 29 and 30 under the system
of care
uh what we wanted to do was to increase
the funding to pay for the children
residential rates
we looked at what the the governor had
asked we looked for the at the
prioritized need request and it was such
a large amount of money that what we
ended up doing was allocating 60 percent
of the Delta between the governor's
request and and the prioritized need
request so we tried to take care of most
of it and that and that's what that that
funding is uh is this is line 30 that's
Federal money isn't it and that's the
federal match that goes with that
on
um
question
representative Walnut thank you
um back to the system of care
money money for just a minute
um
I think I heard
the department talk about this
when
um we were here that evening and what
they were saying is that when they
originally
started going out for these contracts
the contracts came in
a certain amount providers bid on them
and they were awarded but as the
department has
um
received from the providers the actual
cost of care over the last
couple of years
the cost of care is actually much higher
than what the contracts had provided for
these are providers who are caring for
our children there's I think four to
five hundred of them in group homes
residential facilities
without these These are the kinds of
programs that without the right funding
are really in Jeopardy of of closing and
I think
in past histories I can remember hearing
about group homes that close and usually
it is financial issues that um that end
up closing them so
I think this this line in this
particular in this particular document
is really
um
probably very low in order to accomplish
what we need to accomplish remember this
is the line
when we had this the sununu debate last
week this is really where
where we need
places residential care for children who
don't need the level of care that
provided at sununu these are children
who need a lower lower level of care in
their own communities so I am concerned
about this line
did you say the number was 500
I think the I think the department said
it was 500 four to five hundred
there's twenty seven thousand going into
this line for 500.
I would just point out that we've been
building out the system of care for a
while and this is substantially more
than what's in the current budget so it
isn't as though we're not
with this line funding a dramatic and
significant increase it's just not the
tens of millions a year that were
requested
it's it's only seven and a half million
a year you know
so so it's a lot of money and there's a
question at how fast the whole system
can absorb this money as well
further discussion representative
Stringham yeah I'd just like to add a
little bit of shading on that basically
without the the full uh Department
request because of the um
uh process of understanding what the
costs are uh the way that they'll have
to manage this is just to have fewer
residential beds than we have now uh
because the uh uh as
uh representative walner said that
um uh originally they were paying a
certain amount which in good faith
between the department and the
residential housings that were paying
what they thought was cost but now that
they've had experience it's a relatively
new program they understand the costs
are higher so
um you know we have we have a choice of
of uh of following the contract and
paying for fewer Beds which the
department can do or or digging deeper
in the legislature to keep keep the
level of beds where they are now so
and
the line item in here is a kind of a
compromise between those two in my view
representative
thank you Mr chair this question is for
Mr Ripple right lines 29 and 30
reference the same account codes
right with two different amounts what
happens if we adopt 29 but not 30 if we
adopt 29 and 30
line 30 is the federal matching funds
that accompany the general fund
appropriation on line 29. thank you for
the clarity
so Mr chair I I I propose that we just
park this for a little while get through
the rest of HP one and then and then
come back and decide whether you could
decide whether or not you want to vote
it separately
it's up to you if I I I
you know the issue is I want to fund all
this I just don't we just don't have the
money to fund everything so so we funded
this at 60 percent let's let's get
through the rest of hb1 and then folks
can see where else we're prioritizing
and spending money and maybe in a little
broader context we'd be ready to make
that vote you have the experience of how
much was spent in the previous biennium
each year Mr Ripple has that but I did
confirm that this is this is a new money
relative to
the current year is that I don't want to
misstate you you at least said it's a
lot more money than last the current
year so in terms of General funds only
the fiscal 23 adjusted authorized is
18.7 million
for fiscal 24 the number in the
governor's budget plus the 7.4 million
here would total 25.6
so it would be a difference of 18.7 and
23 and 25.6 and 24.
so if there's as few as 500 it was still
over 50 000 per
you don't have the caseload figures in
front of me at the current time
should I continue we could come back
with a slime item all right we'll come
back all right so on page three uh these
items
um
are Are all uh all in one amendment that
we approved yesterday two zero two three
dash one zero six four Hotel
um uh what we did was we carried forward
FY 23 money as restricted revenue and
and with that the effect of that was
that freed up some FY 24 General funds
we we also I wrote the note here plus
this is a fiscal backstop oh plus we
included in the amendment that if this
is not enough money for these Services
the developmental disabilities the
acquired brain disorder the children IHS
waiver that they can go to fiscal and
ask for additional money so
um so that's what this is
the next line item 41
on page four is the New Hampshire
hospital
saying they they
their consumption of personal protective
equipment PPE has been at such a high
rate and the and they project that their
consumption is now at a a new normal
they're using it in in more scenarios
than they have in the past and also the
price has gone up so between pricing and
quantity they said they needed an extra
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year uh above what was in the governor's
budget and so there it is
um
line item 44 was an hb2 item that we
did yesterday and essentially what this
does is it complies with the jail car
observation that the statute probably
includes unconstitutional taxes where
they were looking to have fees and it
also put so we use General funds instead
of uh the uh the taxes that were to be
levied and then we also put a dollar in
for fy24 donations to to get that
account established and seated there
have been a number of organizations
who've said that they support this
program so much we thought we ought to
give them an opportunity to donate to it
so that's line 44 and 45.
um the net on that what we're really
going to provide them is a quarter
million dollars a year for a total of
five hundred thousand
so line item 46
um
the department of administrative
Services historically provided
um shared services uh in a number of
areas to include you know some basic
maintenance and over the course of the
last term Das and DHHS have come to an
agreement that DHHS needs to be more
self-supporting and so to do that
they're adding three additional
positions one administrator and two
maintenance mechanics to do that
what I could never really get my hands
on was whether or not Das was reducing
by three their head count uh I I suspect
they probably aren't I think this is
probably three new people but I that's
just me and my cynicism speaking
um line
48 the Hampstead Hospital everyone I
think in the room knows the Hampstead
Hospital is a relatively a new Venture
for us this is the first full
budget cycle that they that we've the
state has owned them and operated them
and
um and the uh it was said when we
acquired them that their business plan
was sufficient for them to be a viable
ongoing concern
with the state taking over and the state
having additional reasons to admit and
treat people it it it it's clinical
activity that's outside of hampstead's
historical
conduct and so this request a 4.4
million over the biennium is really
there is a in a way as a form of
business insurance we don't have
experience with this model and in case
that they they're spending is at a
higher rate than the budget people think
it'll be this is this is a shock
absorber in the system so that that's
that's what we did we just agreed with
their 4.4 million and we also agreed in
that amendment to convert 21 temporary
positions to
21 permanent positions keeping them full
time
so that's what that Amendment did
and you know with that other than
item 1031 I I I I think the
the committee could vote on the package
and and we could maybe have a separate
vote on 1031 if that's your pleasure
excuse me I said 1031 I'm that's that's
a recommendation page I mean items 29
and 30.
yes Mr chair I'd like to know if we
could um break for a five-minute caucus
for a five minute break please keep it
to that we'll have a five minute break
all right thank you I I skipped over the
veterans some we'll say that real quick
that we didn't have a change for the
Governor's request
you want to use
or run recess
you want to use the division two room
by all means
foreign
committee will come back from Recess
I oh I am I didn't realize you were
waiting for me I'm um okay so
um
Mr chair what I would like to do is I
would like to make a motion to accept
the detailed change from hb1 with the
exception of line 19 on page one that
we've already voted on so I I wouldn't
want it brought back up in this vote and
then with the exception of lines 29 and
30 relative to the funding of the system
of care
uh and so I'd like to vote on the rest
of the package
um
that's so that's my motion second
question in a second to vote for the
remaining parts of hb1 recommendation
from division three sure everyone
understand the motion
sorry to explain something to the clerk
lines 29.
30.
yep
okay so accept detail yep except
discussion representative walner yes
thank you I am gonna I'm gonna vote no I
um I feel that we did actually House
Bill one I do feel that division three
um
did
do a good job on
um
the house bill one
allocations but I'm really concerned
right now about having the system of
care being voted for separately because
I don't know what the outcome is going
to be of that so I'm going to vote no at
this point on the package but it's not
because I don't think that we didn't we
did a lot of we did do a lot of good
things in there
um but I think the system of care is
really important and I don't not knowing
where what the outcome will be I I'm
going to vote no
so we're not voting on system of care at
this time if you want to have that vote
first we could ask representative
Edwards if you'd make that motion she
had made the request during the break
and Mr chair because you and I had
agreed to do it the other way I didn't
want to cause turmoil for you I I other
than that I the order is going to get us
the same place I don't think it's going
to change the system of care vote you
know and it was more logical to just get
everything we could out of the way
before we came back to System of care
but I I really have You'll wish if you
want to continue with your motion we
will do so today is another day of
professional courtesy and if that's what
representative Wallner would like to do
is to vote on system of care first lines
uh 22 through 23 with your with your
flexibility I I'm willing to do that
lines 29 and 30. 29 and 30 on page two
yeah so so I'll withdraw the previous
motion and uh instead move that we move
uh to vote Yes to fund lines 29 and 30.
the the key issue is uh the general
funds because the federal funds flow
from that uh at
14.854 million dollars as shown
so any any further discussion or
questions on the motion to vote on lines
29 and 30 system of care you need a
second motion is second by represent
Edwards do you have the okay Edwards
yes
someone had a you have a question
I continue to think that that line is
underfunded and that we're going to
we're going to end up having problems
during this biennium without those rate
increases there for the Department to
negotiate contracts with these
residential providers I remind you these
are 24-hour providers it's very
expensive they're having a very hard
time finding Workforce this is this is
the exactly kind of service we want for
children
it isn't incarceration it's in the
community it keeps the kids in the
community they um
can often continue in their own schools
this is the place where we should be
putting our money and um
I'm just sorry that we are not that we
at this point are not increasing this
line
if if I may uh we we I I believe the
vote in division three uh on this
particular issue was probably 5-4
and if if the world was filled with
infinite amounts of money I think we
could have uh spent the 25 million or so
extra over the current year that had
been requested by a prioritized need but
as it turned out because we had to find
money to put into the Medicaid rate
reimbursement rate increase we had to
find money because our strategic problem
isn't back in that ER boarding area uh
that this is why we we shave this while
still funding the majority of it
representative nordgren followed by
representative Stringham thank you Mr
chair
um I I guess I would refer us to the
paragraph on page two of our spreadsheet
that says that
we're we're trying to address provider
capacity that's insufficient to meet the
current demand but we're only funding it
60 percent so we're also missing out on
Federal match
um so I guess I'm concerned that we
really needed to make this a priority
and now
we're shortchanging it thank you
represent a string and followed by
represent and not you okay represent
home
thank you Mr chair
we only have so much funds I would like
to note that the current budget is going
up
between hb1 and hb2
just shy of a billion dollars in new
spending between last biennium and this
biennium we have done an enormous amount
of increases in spending for various
activities but we can't do everything
I think the 60 number was a reasonable
number
representative hack and Phillips
followed by representative
thank you Mr chair
um
I just want to um
draw the committee's attention to the
fact that you know the consequence of
not filling this request
to the full ask is that
you know there will be spillover into
the tertiary health health care System
across the state so you know having an
intimate knowledge of many of the folks
at dhmc and that supporting Network
Dartmouth Health across our state
uh you know I am aware that the system
is currently teetering uh on
availability of beds and we are talking
about being on the edge of a very
serious health care crisis in our state
and Across the Nation
um you know I think the consequence of
us not stepping up to the system of care
full additional request to ask is that
you know we are going to further push
our tertiary system into a deeper hole
which will cost far more to dig out than
just supporting the system of care
so my my urgency cannot be expressed
appropriately for you know where we are
as a state and a nation
in this current crisis uh which is about
to get worse and you know my
my suggestion would be to pull into the
pockets of our Surplus for year 23 and
and to consider um you know what we can
do with that bottom line
to meet the system of care I think it's
of critical importance and it will be a
huge mistake to to move forward as if
nothing you know as if there wasn't a
larger consequence down the road there
is so we should be aware of that
I will remind the members we have a hard
stop at noon some of us have a meeting
we have to go to so if we don't finish
up we'll have to come back after lunch
all right I do have two more items after
this we may not get through them
representative Earth has a question
uh just to point out
this was a prioritized needy of the
department
the governor didn't fund it at all when
they did at zero
um we funded it at 60 and I would point
out that this whole discussion did not
occur during our division three meetings
in the context of maybe we shouldn't
increase Medicaid rates as much to allow
for more spending here
furthermore we're only partly through
the process the Senate has yet to
consider this whole process the whole
bill the whole budget
um so I don't think this is the LA I
know this isn't the last shot at
adjusting this
um if the Senate looks at everything and
decides they should
change the way things are allocated
thank you
further discussion
the motion is
to accept lines 29 and 30.
are you ready for the question the clerk
will call a role on the acceptance of 20
lines 29 and 30 on page two then the hb1
presentation from division three
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes president McGuire yes
representative Petri VOC yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative whole yes representative
Sweeney yes
represent Kimbrell's yes representative
Mueller yes
representative Wallner no
Representative norgren no
representative leishman yes
representative Weber no
representative Hewitt
yes
version of Heath no
representative Murray yes
version of evil yeah
yeah representative
no
original hicken Phillips
Stringham yes
president Weiler
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 19-6 in favor of
the motion
okay that's adopted move on uh now for
the rest of the package on the unvoted
items so we've voted uh on line 19 we
voted on lines 29 and 30 so that the
remaining of the packet I would move to
be approved second
for a second to approve the rest of the
packet further discussion
not seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call a roll on
approval of the remaining parts of hb1
Division III recommendations
thank you Mr chairman
representative
I'm sorry
Maguire representative McGuire
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney
representative Edwards representative
Bean
it was in a hole
it was in a Sweeney Arizona Kimbrell's
there's been a pop of each and Mueller
yes
representative walner
representative norgren
I'm sorry
no no
I'm sorry can I go back to uh
representative walner did I hear a
okay just to make sure
very good thank you
representative leishman
Arizona bucco
representative Weber no
representative Hewitt yes
version of Heath
yes
representative Murray yes
version of uh evil yes
Representative no
representative Phillips
yes
Mr chairman a vote is 21-4 in favor of
the motion
that's adopted so so my last item and
and we're going to have to come back but
if I could just Tee It Up for people to
think about and discuss if they want to
over their lunch uh we we identified
um late last night we've tried to work
very collaboratively on uh on this the
amendment
1183 which was the Medicaid
reimbursement rate hikes
um what what we found is in an effort to
use the the the blue template with some
red numbers that we ended up with a
mismatch and the amount of money
allocated for the ambulance services and
I know of two ways that we could address
the what has become a technical problem
and but I I was just it was just
whispered to me that there could be a
third so so I'm going to try to resolve
that and and bring forward what I think
a proper motion is after listening to
everyone
okay
we will now go in recess for lunch some
of us have a meeting that may go past
one o'clock I beg your Indulgence and
patience we'll be back as soon as we can
we are in recess
okay enjoy the lunch
been given LBA which here he is I've
been given LBA overnight to to finish up
any things and bring us the results
tomorrow at 10 we'll see the final
results and we'll
get a briefing from LBA on what the
changes have been and we'll have a final
vote tomorrow
representative Edwards I'm going to
start with good news Mr chairman uh
there's only one more item from division
three not two uh what we're going to
talk about is
on if you if you still have the packet
from yesterday to the division three hb2
packet
and then if you were to flip to page 21
and then if you were to stick your
finger on line 14 of page 21 of the
division three hb2 packet
I kind of wait until it looks like
people aren't doing paper anymore
okay so so the issue that we ran into is
that
the community had asked in the ambulance
line for uh for 2.2 million dollars
per year and
um and that's what that's what we had
agreed on but we also wanted to adopt
the structure that representative
Stringham included
by pulling in the detail of the
ambulance codes that you see at line
from line 16 to 20. will upon further
review and Analysis representative
Stringer Stringham noticed that if we
Implement these rates then we don't have
enough money in in this line 12
item what is that 19 used in Roman
numerals I think that's 19. and so the
quandary was do we put more money in or
do we just remove the rates and while I
was away the smarter people got together
and figured out now let's let's leave
them the amount of money alone on the
possibility that that amount might might
change but we don't know that it will
but it might but if it doesn't what the
what the proposal is and you should have
it in your hand is that we would add the
phrase at the bottom where it says if
the department determines that the
Appropriations contained in this sub
paragraph are insufficient to set rates
to specified levels it may delay the
implementation until such time as the
rate increases can be provided so so in
other words
keeping the amount of money alone that
we we voted on yesterday
um what this new sentence would do is
add flexibility so that if the rate
increase couldn't really go into effect
until say November because that's when
there'd be enough money then then
November it is and then if some more
money were added to this and it could
become October or earlier or something
so I I like the flexibility the
Departments with the flexibility I think
represents Stringham Mooney irf all
talked about this they're all okay with
this approach and so I would uh although
that doesn't have an official amendment
number I I would like to have a vote on
adding this paragraph to what would be a
new line 21 22 and 23 of of
of page 21 of the H house bill 2.
all the members understand the proposal
second the motion
motion by representative Edwards
seconded by representative money
question by representative McGuire thank
you Mr chairman I'm just curious why the
first number is 13 and the others are in
the hundreds is is one like minutes and
the other is hours or something like
that
uh I'll go to the committee expert
representative Stringham
we ounce thirteen dollars it's seven
hundred dollars it's three twenty five
dollars is 450 so we don't have to have
a point zero zero that's true but but uh
um ambulance fees per mile tend to be
dollars and cents and the other fees
tend to be dollars and cents too but
dollars is close enough
so when's miles and ones per hour per
day or something the others are incident
codes
um so you you get miles plus you know if
you have
any any further discussion on the
proposal to change this page in hb2
everybody understands where it is going
to go
Mr chairman representative Emrick yeah I
think I think you misstated that this
three additional paragraphs I think this
looks to me like it's just a a
replacement for paragraph 19.
um with the addition of that last
paragraph okay I I think technically
you're correct but everything is the
same until you get to the part where it
says if the department determines so so
the way it would look in your
um in your new hb2 would be those three
sentences would get added because none
of the words above it in uh section 19
change we totally I'm just saying I
think you want to get the the motion
correct it just becomes part of that
paragraph it didn't add a new
it doesn't add 20. so it pushes
makes 19 bigger that's all right okay
yes representative Erv just to be clear
the first paragraph is somewhat
different as well is it yeah yep
representative stringham's request the
first paragraph removes the provision
stating that ambulance EMT Medicaid fee
levels shall be set at Medicare fee
levels with the following exceptions
all right
so I'll say instead I motion that we
adopt this piece of paper
and I'll second the motion
is the motion understood
there's no further discussion the clerk
will call a roll on accepting the
replacement of item 19 in hp2 on page
free
thank you Mr chairman
um representative yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes Arizona Mooney yes
Rosanna Edwards yes represent a bean yes
version of hole is not here
it was in a Sweeney yes
yes representative Campbell's yes
representative Mueller yes
representative Waller yes
representative norgren yes
president Leachman yes
representative Weber
yes
Arizona Buco yes
representative Hewitt yes
uh representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes represent of
evil yes
representative tolorski yes
Arizona haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham
yes
Rosanna water yes Mr chairman of vote is
24-0 in favor of the motion
uh thank you very much to the committee
uh division three thank you appreciate
it
um
I'll ask the
the LBA members
to tell us what your plan is for
tomorrow
yeah I don't think I can find it Mr
chair I believe the plan is for us to
put all this together and you'll hear
from Michael Kane around 10 o'clock 10
o'clock all right so I authorize the LBA
I hereby authorize the LBA to make any
Technical and mechanical changes
necessary to reflect the intent of the
committee
and so let's see tomorrow's the 29th
we'll recess this committee till
tomorrow at 10 o'clock for final
examination of the budget
and tomorrow we'll celebrate with cake
that all of you have gained us
only if the budget passes